[Music]
this is India the only element in the
universe that is safe and soft enough to
chew like bubble gum I've had this lump
of indium for years but I've never taken
a bite out of it until now
actually biting it wasn't as hard as I
expected it was kind of like
refrigerated Milk Duds it softened as it
warmed up in my mouth and as I chewed it
I could tell it was metal I could feel
the vibrations of the crystals twinning
it had absolutely no taste chewing it
was like chewing bubble gum on a
freezing cold day you know when you
breathe in the cold air and the gum gets
hard it was almost softer than that but
it's probably not the best thing for
your teeth so don't do this at home oh
and by the way it's also just soft
enough to write with it kind of sticks
to your teeth but overall I would give
it a 9 out of 10. and if you think that
sounds High keep in mind that the
periodic table also puts indium close to
10.
thank you